by this point it's pretty clear that
China and not Russia is the top threat
the United States faces globally China
has far more people a much larger
economy they're also far more aggressive
they're hackers steal more us secrets
military secrets and intellectual
property the state-owned companies have
far more thoroughly penetrated the
American economy Senator Marco Rubio is
one of the few lawmakers trying to
spread awareness of the threat we face
from the Chinese government to that end
he discussed a protest vote against the
defense funding bill afterwards he spoke
to us in his first Fox News interview
following that vote senator thank you
for coming on tonight
so you have for the first time voted
against the National Defense
Authorization Act as a form of protest
if I'm getting this right yeah and
hopefully to get people to notice we did
something about allowing this Chinese
telecommunications company to stay in
business I personally don't believe we
should be allowing any Chinese
telecommunication company to do business
in America because they use it as a tool
of espionage they do it all over the
world and what I mean by espionage is
not just like listening in on people's
calls I'm talking about taxpayer-funded
research at universities they steal it
and all of a sudden it shows up and
their products I'm talking about
intellectual property of companies and
key industries I'm talking about defense
secrets and we are creating an
environment in which they can put
backdoors and de servers and steal these
things from us and let me just make one
more polkas at the intro you kind of
touched upon it there is no greater
threat to the United States because
China seeks to replace us and we're
still struggling in this country because
for the first time since the end of the
Cold War we now have a near peer
adversary and a near peer adversary that
is looking to overtake us and frankly
we're helping them and we're helping
them not just by giving them business in
our country but through trade practices
that have allowed them to cheat and
steal for 18 years
there are reports and they're there many
stories like this but here's one that is
emergencies recently Google apparently
is planning to do the bidding in effect
of the Chinese government to censor its
search engine in China helping to prop
up an authoritarian regime what should
we make of that well we should make of
it that American companies by and large
who like for example to march up and
through the country here and take up on
all sorts of social issues and lecture
Society have no problem helping China
censor as an example but it goes deeper
than that I don't know if you know or
require aware project maven in which
Google was working with the Department
of Defense to help them with targeting
actually would save lives by allowing
the military to avoid hitting civilians
well because of pressure from their
employees Google no longer works as a
Department of Defense
however they work in partnership with
the University in China that provides
all the technology assistance to the
Chinese military so it's just one more
example of this rampant hypocrisy of
American companies who are who are more
interested in making a few dollars
gaining access to the 1.3 billion person
Chinese market but have no problem on
the other hand cutting ties with the
country that allowed them to exist in
the first place the United States so
they're serving the police state but
ignoring their own country is Russia
doing anything on the scale that China
is here no very different I mean China
look Russia is a country in the economy
of Russia is 2 trillion dollars that's
our GDP that's that's the size of
Italy's and Spain's they have nuclear
weapons there we've got a deal with them
because they have nuclear weapons they
have some pretty good conventional
capabilities and and they are going out
and doing the sorts of things to sort of
pit us against each other and and and
sort of it's not in favor of one
political party or the other they just
want us to fight against each other
is important the Chinese threat is
critical Russia has no ability and no
willingness to overtake us in the
geopolitical stage China seeks to
replace us and they used to hide that
intention now they're pretty aggressive
and open about it and it's time we open
up to that reality and start fighting
back we most certainly should not be
helping them do that by allowing them to
steal our intellectual property and our
military secrets so why is nobody saying
this why is every single news conference
out of Washington about Russia and no
one's saying anything about China I
thought I find it odd well you know
we're in a better place than we were two
years ago but not where we need to be
you know we spent about 17 years the
conventional wisdom was that China was a
poor country and if we just help them
let him cheat let him steal because once
they get rich they'll behave like us
that was that was a bad that was didn't
work out a terrible idea and we're
paying the price for it now which is why
I support these tariffs look I don't
like tariffs you know the best way to
get rid of these tariffs is to be
willing to impose them yourself in
retaliation that's the only thing
they'll understand and you're seeing the
impact of it already the Chinese economy
is beginning to struggle as a result of
this we got a bunch of people in this
country that want to unconditionally
surrender and and/or allow China to do
anything they want in America so long as
we get some crumbs for our companies in
terms of doing a little bit of business
over there as long as Google gets richer
senator thank you very much for that
perspective it's a natural that needed I
appreciate it thank you